I have a question are you virgin you're
traditional you're virgin are you a
virgin
in that aspect I'm not gonna comment on
me being a virgin or not but what I'm
gonna say is every every human being
should be able to cook
tradition and modernization that
survives you know I need to cook to
survive can I can I ask Miss to say
something right I'm gonna ask you
something sure right because I I can't I
don't like [__] right and like
there's not some people that I can't
remember I'm gonna talk to him because
so far he's talking sense thank you very
much thank you it's giving pick me right
who said pick me listen they want me
don't look at me
I don't want to talk to you
I've been with my man for 32 years
32 years I don't need to clap for myself
because I'm happy I'm not here and what
I was gonna ask him right is how would
you think a woman would you think that
woman would you think that woman who's
calm down I'm I'm loud I'm actually
little chops right and that's the
problem that women have got oh gee they
don't want to be doing no paint jobs
why do you need a man in a relationship
be
a partner which companionship
romantic love things that you can't get
by yourself you want to go on dates with
him it's not about I need someone to fix
my car like go to a mechanic You're Not
Safe call the police
wait wait what about a father to your
kids
you can be around I definitely want that
these other stuff this is the reason
I agree wait wait wait it's not it's not
that you want it you need it I agree and
these are the stuff that I need in a man
but it's like at the end of the day it's
not like I completely need you but I
want the whole but the whole point is if
the lights went out tomorrow you would
need a man it's a side to
agreements I'm saying if if the lights
went out tomorrow you would need someone
to protect you of course in a society
not my boyfriend off of my exes can't
even do anything that's actually another
problem a lot of men can't do much you
know what I mean not everybody
in this day and age guys can't even say
attire you can't yeah my mind can't do
this my man can't do that what and you
want to settle down why would you go and
choose a man
that can't do these things that you
wanted them to do because my man could
do all the blues I need a man because
most men grow up with a place
no that's the truth speak for yourself
speak for yourself
my boyfriend you know what I need a
father to my children I don't need
something right
she needs a farmer for her children
right so she's gonna go out there right
and you're gonna buy your child an
electric car you're gonna go and buy
your child a bicycle Who the hell's
gonna play the bicycle and fix the
electric car who doesn't do it you've
got YouTube I know how to do these
things
yourself go and get some sperm done or
something because you obviously don't
need a man that's the future the future
for who no Society because
yeah
let me finish talking right now you can
you got a man right and you've been busy
all day right and you're in your bed at
one o'clock in the morning and your man
comes in with all of his friends
and said oh babes all the friends are
here they're hungry what you're gonna do
yeah I'll cook for my man I I'm
making people stop cooking they think
that
you know it's everything it's not just
about cooking they always saying
everything anyway Mr take like I was
saying before we got really interrupted
right now if you'd is this your idea of
a woman that you think deserves a man
I'm here
single but I'm looking
I mean I like taking you if you want to
hook me up let me know and I just want
any of anybody but choose how does that
make you feel well is that kind of woman
that you think deserves a man well he's
a top G you can't be asking him this
question
for yourself
um
I made my point
to go to the to go my man said to me
you're not going what would you do
I'm gone what would you do
why why why am I not going it doesn't
matter he said to you that's coming up
because that's just illogical submission
no but the whole the whole point is you
pick someone that you respect enough to
trust his judgment even because even
when you disagree I want to I want to
fight that I don't agree with it
just because you're in a relationship
wait wait wait we need one at a time why
would you think it's something stupid or
whatever you trust a man enough to be
with him you trust him I enough to sleep
with him so why won't you trusted
opinion why does he have to give the
everyone say to my man like if I say to
my man don't do this the first thing is
you're thinking not she's telling me
what to do there must be a reason behind
it why she's telling me not to do
because it's not a comment when I came
on your show they were in my DMs I'm
thinking do you not have things to do
with your life like the fact that you
sit on post little comments and then
come into my my social media and then
slide in my DMs like just
over it that's just the internet though
like I get death threats I get like
people make videos it's just I mean I
just think like you go on the internet
duh
like yeah you're gonna get insulted on
the internet
who hasn't been but it's obviously it's
quite hard especially when you're
receiving a lot of hate from all these
men
I've had hundreds of videos made on Tick
Tock like that go after my appearance it
happens to me like everything
okay one one I called her a whale after
she attacked me after she she attacked
me she knocks the mic out of my hand she
called me a slag I didn't know what that
meant at the time okay I had no idea
what that meant she called me a slag put
the mic out of my so of course I'm gonna
call her will you you attacked me first
that's what they never talk about you
got to call them well because you
attacked me I missed a good episode of
something
it was a street interview and this girl
she like knocks the mic out of my hand
and they're pulling her back you I'll
have you you slag and I was like drunken
female but it was like it was like that
was a response I've never called someone
on my show a whale individually but when
I come in your show you were quite rude
to me I'm not gonna lie no I'm not gonna
lie the way you conduct your like show
today today was great but when I was on
your show last time you were like why
you talk too much I'm thinking who is
this woman talking to me like that I'm
not a child but that's the thing because
you can't you kept interrupting
everybody the whole show no that's what
happened you have dinner
because because I'm the host yeah and so
so today it's like we have we have a big
guest though I'm gonna I'm gonna let him
talk but you're in no offense you're
just a normal guest and normal guest we
don't let dominate the entire
conversation
you were you probably talked 70 of the
time and so I have to interrupt you and
stop you because you're talking and
nobody else in the room and nobody else
in the room had a chance to talk I
understand I interrupt people but that's
part of your job as a host is to control
the conversation and if anything I
probably control the conversation less
than I should compared to most hosts no
but I think it's the way that you were
rude you could just be like okay let him
let the next person talk you were like
why are you talking to me that is so
weird because because
we had tried multiple times to tell you
nicely
multiple times to tell you nicely and it
just had to ask it just kept escalating
that is not true I think you're trying
to guess like me right now because
that's not true the thing is you didn't
agree what I was saying and then you
resulted you and Auntie resulted to
insults
but that's the reason I would say I'm
not coming for you right now because you
know what it's your show but what I'm
trying to say for us but you're not
coming for us no just open your mouth
listen what I'm trying to say what I'm
trying to say is
no how was I really why you called my
name into I was I rude to you but you
were rude how was Our Roots you were
rude this is this is just my point of
view you you told a story where you said
another you didn't say you're too nice
about it you'll find it too nice
I don't care right now because you went
on the streets
again please just please calm down don't
tell me about calm down
hang on I had Mr Tate talking right with
passion and loud I had no wait time to
calm down right you're there shouting
off your mouth right I am very loud I am
being loud I don't tell me about calm
down because when he was talking he was
just screeching that listen right as far
as I'm concerned don't even think about
coming on per show and disrespecting her
you've done it already and now you're
coming back here to do it again Pearl
wasn't rude to you she was right that
wasn't rude to you yes you know what
because he spoke the truth
because at the end of the day it's all
out there if you don't know what a woman
is and you can't say what a woman
have some money
[Music]
if you're getting abused and you're
worried about how it's gonna see because
there's enough cameras I know it's
America but in the UK
this goes back to the equity not
equality like I said I would say the
same way that goes for gun semi goes for
a man if that is happening what you do
you get up and you leave as a man you're
strong enough to either restrain her or
to run away from her because you love me
just say like this when it's done you
run not fast I swear to God if my
brother was being hit like that from a
bit I swear to God knock that [__] out
I swear to Jesus the moment she lives
and it hits you just run or just
constrain you can have your hands like
this
that [__] is hitting my brother like no
knock her out yeah no sympathy I don't
care if you have to reconstruct your
whole goddamn face I don't you shouldn't
have hit you shouldn't hit first you're
not a child you're a grown woman
because one hit from a man can knock
around she'll die no
and this is what I said Equity like a
man this is let's not forget the fact
that a man is way way physically
stronger than him that's why women
exposure wait wait wait wait wait listen
listen I get that I get that but this is
what I'm just about to say if that is
the case I think it's incredibly
extremely irresponsible to tell somebody
to do something like hit her back
because hey hey I did not say hit her
back I said knock that [__] out would
you have back no bro you here so what
you wanted to land only because you
didn't land there as hard enough that's
your business you wanted to land it you
didn't land well you landed it so for me
who hit first don't hit first be
expected to hit back because it's
instinct when someone comes for you what
did you say I'll come for you back I'll
come for you back when London everybody
does that you're gonna go from the best
Nigerians understand this intrinsically
beat anybody you cannot be if you cannot
fight them don't fight in the first
place
is not your size don't go simple this
has happened to you like a couple of
guys that I know where they get into a
fight
and then they knock the guy this is
knocking a guy out that's why I've been
in fact so it's more conditioned for
these things he knocks him out and
actually he gave him a brain hemorrhage
and he died the guy that he punched no
I'm gonna tell you if you're telling
somebody to knock her out so maybe it's
already not even conditioned to fight
she's only fighting you because she
feels like she can't because you're
supposed to listen do not knock people
out what you do it's not it's not you
don't it doesn't mean if you got first
what if that first punch knock me out
what if that first punch give me a
concussion which one if she was the man
I'm the man I'm the woman the one man
okay Lucio the man I now hit you because
ah you can't hit me bam what if that
first hit give you a concussion give all
right question cool so why does he only
have to count for me because oh if he
needs me back no bruh you're here so
what you wanted to land only because you
didn't land there as hard enough that's
your business you wanted to land it it
didn't land well you landed it so for me
first don't hit first be expected to hit
back because it's Instinct once one
comes for you what did you say I'll come
for you back I'll come for you back when
London everybody does that why do we why
do we always take away the consequence
for women like why do we like because
this is what you're doing you're saying
the normal consequence if you if girl
girl boy boy is if you hit someone even
if they're stronger than you you will
get hit back you will probably be
knocked out but when it's boy girl for
some reason we get a a pass why is the
same way that you wouldn't put a woman
and a man in a boxing ring
okay but if the woman signed up if the
woman said put me in this boxing ring I
would let her go if she said if she said
I am signing up volunteering to go box
let the [__] go right if she's playing
boxes okay dude you get hit back I'll
give you I'll give you another example
because what we saw was no more examples
let me tell you what you saw was
shocking if you want you can go and
search for a lot of these like NFL
players and baseball players and a lot
of these men that have abused that women
left for instance and see what abuse
from a man looks like
the strength levels are totally
different yeah
no stop it my love what what about those
couples that the woman is bigger than
the man
is bigger than the man the man likes big
women it's fine she likes them small is
fine she's strong thank you and she
feels like she can drag him like he's
one of her kids and I say the same thing
that I said boys if you're strong
restrainer and then walk away girls or
boys if you're not stronger bloody
protect yourself and run from the
situation
oh
yeah
knock that [__] don't knock that [__]
out now let's hear from the girls do you
think most girls are objective or do you
think they think they're hotter than
they are
or do they underrate themselves go
around personally I think it depends on
the person because growing up I'm
obviously not skinny hi everyone I'm not
skinny so growing up I was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted up by
people blah blah blah blah and I was
just the other one you know so like I
never really thought of myself as
an attractive person like I would never
call myself anything more than a four
but now like I don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like I've
grown into myself and I've I've I'm
comfortable with who I am now that like
even if uh you guys call me delusion or
whatever I think I'm maybe not a 10
let's not go that far but like
definitely an eight per so like whether
you guys think I am or not yeah that's
got nothing to do with her how many how
many dates have you guys gone on one
okay yeah we went on one maybe very last
that was our first first date
go ahead sorry so now we'll go I guess
on a second one
but he's kind of short he's only like
five nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
I'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really yeah manifesting a tall man
one of the other guys I'm talking to is
six foot seven
oh wow
oh there's another guy who I just made
this whole Tick Tock about who was like
all about me asked me out calling me all
these pet names my love and all this
[__] and then we're talking and I was
like oh you have the vaccine right and
he was like no I was like you're not
vaccinated and you want to go out with
me I'm like I'm not going out with you
you're not vaccinated what are you
expect me to be kissing you you're not
vaccinated really oh I wouldn't care I
don't care
it just where you have to be vaccinated
like I work at a yoga studio where we're
requiring proof of vaccination that's
where I'm at right now holding all this
laundry through all these music
festivals where they're requiring proof
of vaccination and to me it's so much
deeper than just like do you or don't
you it's about that like I don't want to
have that debate with you right like
clearly if we don't view it the same way
we're not in alignment so would you not
would you not date someone that was
different than you like politically no I
wouldn't what are what are your
standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
I mean politically I definitely want us
to have the same view you know I'm a
black woman right so I'm not going to
date a white Republican that would just
be a headache like why would we do that
to ourselves
okay friends we wouldn't travel in the
same circles and we don't view this the
world's arguments okay just gonna turn
into a fight later
yeah no so what like what else
um
well they have to have a car this other
guy who didn't have a vaccine he didn't
have a car I was like how are you coming
to take me out you don't have a car you
know I'm not driving anywhere yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car
um I've also realized that I want
someone that has like some sort of
creative or like job and entertainment
like I have
you have to be very ambitious because I
am very ambitious I want to be able to
like you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night I want us to be able to
come together and talk about all of the
exciting things that happen in each of
our lives right like okay this other guy
was like well I'm not rich I'm a regular
guy and I was like that's fine but like
I'm not a regular girl like I'm I'm not
so like if you're if you are gonna date
me like either you have to be able to
handle that or you yourself also wants
to not be like regular like I don't
think like just an average person like
because do you care okay would you be
cool if a guy that makes less money but
he's very he's a hard worker like he's
ambitious
yeah okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him you wouldn't be able
to afford my engagement ring I'm getting
an eight carat cushion cut vintage
engagement ring if you make forty five
thousand dollars a year it would take
what
four years no eight years but how much I
don't know anything about Rings how much
how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a 200 000
are you insane
my ring has to Sparkle from across the
street like you have to do that [__]
it's gonna blind people that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right I go to yoga with this girl
who has an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an Audi so it's about more
than just it's about the fact that you
can afford that okay well I'm just
thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because I'm telling you know but not not
in a good way not in a good way I'm
telling you like my dad would if my mom
asked for that from my dad my dad would
have told her to go find a new boyfriend
because there's no way in hell he was
gonna spend two hundred thousand dollars
on an engagement ring and that's
something no and that's a
multi-millionaire in the top half a
percent who had ten kids my mom never
he
wasn't that originally right he wasn't
well he was making like six figures in
his early 20s oh nice so so any any
women woman with half a brain would
think this is a good this is a good but
my dad's like he's good with money he's
not like like to me that's like such an
unwise investment to spend 200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my God no no oh my God no that's like
I would rather put that in a college
fund for our kids or like yeah they'll
have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know status is going up like I
just did a music festival where I made
30 grand over the weekend in one weekend
you know what I mean like I need
somebody who can be on that level right
but the problem is like guys don't care
about your money
under there I I know but it doesn't like
you know like
I'm just I think you're gonna miss out
on a lot of guys with like this like to
me these are like crazy high so today I
listen to my dating coach she said you
do not get your expectation you get your
minimum standard
is your dating coach married yes and she
has a baby and her wedding ring is at
least five carats yeah and her man is
rich she doesn't even have to okay you
know yourself makes like 30 to 50 Grand
a month coaching women in love
I mean good luck if that like works for
you I just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like I think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no no you just have to have the man
who's okay with maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but I'm just thinking like
like I I I know but those guys that are
making like like that amount of money
like
yeah like I think they typically want
like the young like 21 22 year olds
what
I'm 30. so I'm not that old I'm actually
no I'm an age to be wiped up by somebody
who's like in their 40s and like ready
to be serious and start popping out
babies a 21 year old unless you're Kylie
Jenner is realistically too young to be
like popping out kids
like you're
someone that can make that amount of
money in a shorter period of time like
somebody who is a musical artist right a
YouTube producer somebody who's in
entertainment somebody who's on a TV
show somebody who does like concerts and
tours amount of money isn't the same to
them you know what I mean
what do you mean like say I was dating
somebody like a to be easy right okay he
makes 150 000 minimum per show minimum
that's what he makes in a show yeah so
if he does a couple shows the 200 Grand
to him he won't even feel it
no but like I this is some coming from
someone like I've been in a relationship
with a guy that was worth over a million
like I've but I would never in a million
years ask him to spend 200k on a ring
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like I'm not entitled to
his money but women are like pathetic or
need a man or XYZ it's like no baby back
yourself
we do we don't need them because they do
no because they're lesbians who do you
who do you call to get your car fixed a
man or a woman your toilet breaks down
who do you call so I fix my own car I
can I can do it I'm most mechanics my
power your power supply who runs it who
runs the infrastructure of society so we
don't choose we don't have to remember
no not at all
but do you not think do you not think
would you agree that women decide who
have sex
yeah so would you not think that it is
men who decide who gets married
next a woman can say no or a woman can
ask and a woman has the ability to be
like look if you're not gonna commit to
me I'm gonna walk away no I know but men
can also say no to sex right but we
understand that culturally when it comes
to having sex it is women who decide to
get access yeah but you women usually
don't say no to marriage either
the majority of women who are proposed
to accept
um I don't yeah I don't know statistic
that also and again it's because what I
mean is like you know you know that when
you stay or from the first day of a guy
you know that he would have sex with you
straight away
so nine times out of ten a guy who's
ready to have sex before the woman
that's why she has the power to who has
sex right
but also nine times out of ten it is the
woman who is ready for the commitment so
he decides who he commits to and I think
that's what Pearl's saying saying that
when it comes to marriage I think here's
the thing like before any woman has sex
with a guy she has he has to qualify
himself to her before she accepts that
intimacy right
so the same is true that women have to
qualify themselves to men if they want
relationship and commitment but then so
this then the falls back to the
patriarchy why is it the women are the
ones who are like I have to look good I
have to be hairless well why do the men
have to say oh I have to have a good job
I have to like a girl could be
unemployed a dude will still date her
but like men have to qualify themselves
to women too it's like like you're
trying to like take away the things that
men care about yeah and the things that
like the things that women and men care
about just are yeah well that's that's
why I'm very I'm I'm so frustrating and
that I'm very gray area I'm right so
that's it I've had men that are broke
men that uh
objects I'm gonna say objectively not
very good looking men that are short men
that actually bring little to the table
other than being nice right and um so
but would you would you prefer a man
that like I would prefer yeah I would
100 prefer a man that brought me more
offered me more but it didn't stop me
from dating other men it didn't stop me
right but then I think I still find the
anomaly in that but I'm saying like you
would still prefer the man that had more
just like the man would still prefer the
woman that had had less guys yeah and I
think like like it just is I'm not
saying I mean I mean it's not like you
know I
like double standards just are yeah yeah
I was gonna say as well do you know um
I think the difference is that and this
goes back to like what you were saying
earlier what you've all said earlier is
I understand the notion of you know you
said oh but you should want someone who
loves you for you but we all
acknowledged earlier earlier that love
isn't conditioned is not unconditional
like love is very or if we say love at
least who we choose is definitely
conditional and some like you could meet
a guy who you think oh he rocks my world
intimacy wise but if you want to start
having a family and he's really not
doing anything with his life it's like
you may really care about him but you
may not choose him over the next guy who
can do that for you does that make sense
yeah and then I think it also depends
upon like I'm gonna be real it really
depends upon your mental health your
well-being you're like so I settled for
people who treat me like [__] and if if
someone from outside when Amy this is
what this guy is doing to me I'd be like
are you confused like leave him like
what the [__]
um and yeah like I fully like agree with
that I fully agree that like that's it's
just not a simple yes or no would you
would you would you then go back because
love is conditional would you go back on
your statement that like the man
shouldn't love you for you like it's
it's conditional based on the choices
yeah like that's it so yeah that makes
sense so so you would agree then to to
younger ones just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible